hello and welcome to the special edition
of spectator TV
um now James and Katie is the second day
after the budget or not budget the
Autumn statement what are the front
pages like today Katie so there's a
mixed bag I mean I think the express is
the most positive
um but that's not hugely surprising and
they're happy about the pensions exactly
so I think and that and look that was
the moment when you saw Jeremy Hunt
delivering the Autumn statement where
the Tory MPS the the back benches were
pretty quiet throughout and it's
definitely when he announced the
pensions triple lock
um staying in place that you saw the
loudest cheers will at least but you
know the most animation in the session
coming from the Tory benches and the
expresser celebrating that same they've
had a campaign I mean away from that I
think the focus is on if you look at the
obr forecast the fact that uh projectors
have that big Fallen living standards
and then I think you're also seeing uh
people saying well how do we get into
this mess and therefore we know are the
tourists cleaning up their own mess so
but I would say if you take a step back
I think all things considered I don't
know what James thinks here ultimately I
don't think the front pages are so bad
for the for all the difficult things
they've had to enhance these front pages
were never going to be good and I think
they could be a lot worse James so I
think the most important test of this
awesome statement was how the markets
reacted and the market reaction so far
you know there haven't been hosannas or
anything like that but but it but it but
it hasn't been negative we're not we're
not dominated we are not currently
having a split screen with guilt yields
and Sterling you know so I think that
bit has passed I think there is
obviously grumpiness among tour MPS you
saw Jacob Reese morgue's interview on
channel 4 news last night but you
haven't got people saying oh I'm gonna
vote against this and I think the other
crucial thing is
um budgets or Autumn statements or
fiscal events unravel when individual
measures get picked off and get pulled
out you're not seeing that happen at the
moment now
I think the crucial thing is whether the
argument they are making which is you
can't borrow more so you've got to
operate Within These parameters whether
that sticks or not I thought it was
quite interesting yesterday Pat McFadden
uh a lot of Labor treasury spokesman was
was indicating that labor kind of
accepted that you had to kind of keep
within what the obr are saying about the
size of the fiscal consolidation needed
and so we could be having a debate about
you know how to do that precisely
um because I think what is more
politically difficult after what
happened to Liz trust and positive
watching is to argue that you can let
borrowing take the strain and so I think
we now are in a world where uh the
choices that have been imposed and all
the parties are more fiscally
conservative now if you were an aliener
out of space you would think that that
would normally favor the Tories but the
reason it might not is the people who
have discovered the limits of what
government can borrow are actually
conservatives and so labor is very easy
for labor as Rachel we did yesterday to
essentially deliver a statement that is
saying the Tories well this is only
having to be done because of the mess
that the Tory party has made so I think
I think that is the kind of the kind of
the kind of the crucial question about
politics this morning and I think when
you're looking at the reaction
amongstatory MPS to James's Point lots
of people don't particularly like what
they saw yesterday they find these
measures hard to stomach but I think
there is a sense of what is alternative
and you know reaching out to a few MPS
wants to you know
very elegant for this podcast the
general reaction was just meh do you
know I mean because no one's
particularly happy about it but
ultimately what are you gonna do instead
yeah and also this you know and because
they've obviously tried an alternative
and there are still lots of people who
ultimately think that Liz trusses
General approach in terms of going for
growth lower taxes was fundamentally the
right one but the mismanagement of how
you brought that in now means it's not
it's not an option in the same way and
therefore there is a bit I still think
you know let's see what how things look
at the beginning of next week because
you never quite know what's going to
flare up but to James's Point people are
not really talking about any one
specific measure and I think weather's
been the most discomfort is on fuel Duty
I would be surprised if you'll do I mean
Fusion she seems to get Frozen in every
budget I would be surprised if that run
was broken exactly but I do think the
very fact that that's become almost the
issue is a sign that the measures that
Jeremy Hunt actually spoke about are
being broadly accepted and does this
leave labeling a bit of a tricky
positioning I mean James you've pointed
out one way which labor can attack but
ultimately what is their alternative so
I think Labor's view will not I mean
labor will take the people they don't
actually need to provide an alternative
the polls at the moment suggest that the
public blame the conservatives for the
mess that Jeremy Hunt said yesterday he
was trying to fix and so I think Labor's
thing will be just to say well who did
it and do what Rachel Williams did
yesterday which is you know are you
better off now than you were four or
five years ago the answer is about
looking at the obr charts predicting the
the two-year biggest squeeze ever on
people's real household disposable
income will not be yes and I mean labor
at the moment are relying on that being
enough I think the the way in which that
strategy might not be enough is if the
economy has clearly stabilized by the
time in the next election and you know
there is a sense that the corner has
been turned and these tough decisions
have borne through but I think one of
the challenges for Jeremy Hunter when
she seen that is but they have they they
are relying on that turnaround happening
in two years one as you know no normally
this is the kind of statement that gets
delivered at the beginning of a
parliament and you've got four or five
years for it to bear fruit yeah I think
ultimately I mean if you look at the
polls labor in a pretty comfortable
position in terms of how far ahead they
still are to keep saying this was your
mess you know and then I also think in
terms of their own spending plans
they're just at the moment I don't think
they're getting the same even think
about broadcast coverage I think at some
point it's supposed to stay as they are
and index of slavery are going to win a
very large majority potentially larger
than the current Tories currently have
now then they will of course come under
more scrutiny for what exactly they're
going to do but it doesn't really we're
still at the point where you know it's
about two years after this conservative
government and I think labor have some
time on the side and I think Labor's
rationally at the moment is to
essentially have an iconic tax raise to
pay for something popular except the
broad outlines what the Tories are
proposing and then say but we'll tax
non-dorms to pay for more doctors to be
trained yeah so rather than having a
high level argument just kind of
concentrate on something which is
politically taxed an unpopular group of
people to pay for something popular and
try and set that up I mean ultimately it
is the case that what was an act
yesterday was trickier for labor is
tricky of Labor in terms of uh measures
there are plenty of things in there that
labor MPS would support and so it is a
trickier position for them to be in then
Liz trust and quasi quatang is not so
many budget which ultimately labor
didn't have to do much because they
could just say well you were cutting tax
for the richest and you're not you know
offering help for the most vulnerable on
things that benefits you because you
haven't confirmed either way but the the
benefit for labor and the problem of the
Tories is that still happened and
therefore we might be in a different
position in terms of the polls had the
Liz trust not so many budget ever ever
occurred and but because it has you know
this is all just rowing back oh you know
it's almost getting back to the 2019
Manifesto type pitch
um but people obvious remembering what
happened in between and James ultimately
is this going to work to reduce
inflation and to limit how long the
recession is going to be well I mean
that that is the either 64 000 question
I think if we already answered about we
might be it might be very high paid jobs
in the city I'm not sitting here no uh
look I I think what you've got is you've
now got the kind of that
I think the big question is is this
enough in this Autumn statement for the
bank of England for the interest rates
not to go as high as it looked like they
were going to go and uh is the recession
turns out you know to be shallower Than
People expected I think one of the other
big questions is you know there are a
huge numbers of external factors here
you know how much longer does the war in
Ukraine go on for for example
um I think one of the other difficult
other things is uh what what happens in
the rest of the global economy I think
at the moment one of the things is that
none of the engines the global economy
are are going kind of at any great speed
you've got
Europe is obviously dealing with very
high energy prices that that are are
depressing growth you've got a very
tight labor market in the US and a quite
aggressive Federal Reserve tightening
China is still trying to work out how it
wants to handle covert as to You'll post
some coffee house this week so I think
this is I I think there is a that I
think that there are I mean I think the
government as you saw yesterday Jeremy
Hunt took a force when they bunches
trying to blame this on global factors
they're up but they're but there are
clearly Global factors and how what
happens with them I think is going to be
also going to be key in determining the
the pace at which uh the economy
recovers Katie and James thanks very
much